véronique deal ans pédiatre à bombay
sinon bonjour et merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors vous êtes
chef du service de soins palliatifs pour
enfants à l'hôpital la baille dire bye
wadia à bombay où vient donc de le
préciser ce qu aujourd'hui l'inde
voilà est dans une situation dramatique
est ce que le virus est tour de contrôle
finalement contrôle très loin de là
puisque nous sommes dans une main tenant
dans une croissance exponentielle mais
c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas dans
quelle mesure juste que je trouve on va
aller à la très peu de la population est
vaccinée dans l'immédiat nous n'avons
que 113 millions de personnes qui ont
été vaccinées et parmi elles seulement
19 millions ont conçu les deux doses
bien entendu les enfants n'ont pas été
vaccinés et les personnes moins de 45
ans n'ont pas été vaccinés encore et et
tous les hôpitaux sont pleins
alors je ne peux pas généralisée que ce
qui se passe dans chaque dans l'état du
maharashtra à bombay ligier le plus
touché mais dans toute l'inde
en tout cas dans les grandes métropoles
a absolument pas de livres de deux lits
disponibles ou l'aigle et son prix et
dans tous les hôpitaux dans des services
qui ont été fortement heureusement
qu'ils se sont mis en place dans les
hôpitaux aménagé on veut dire depuis un
an pour lovely d'uniquement nous sommes
davantage prêts à la crise à la
situation mais le nombre de malades est
vraiment très très grand
tous les jours il ya un surcroît de
manades
les enfants sont aussi atteints
davantage que lors de la première break
vous parlez de nda manque de lits
on a également évoqué un manque
d'oxygène
muret carrément dans les très peu
d'oxygène on sait que plusieurs hôpitaux
et cliniques ont lancé un appel au
gouvernement central est-ce que cet
appel a été entendu
oui tout à fait cedria aussi des
entreprises privées qui se proposent
pour pouvoir acheminer davantage
l'oxygène dans les étapes sûrement
davantage post - et puis bien sûr à ce
qui s'est passé à la sic donc il devrait
la voir la chose dans l'entré temps
était dans l'accident mais il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'oxygène pas suffisamment
de ventilateurs pour le nombre de
patients qui en auraient besoin
et puis donc la plupart on essaye de
garder le d'envoyer les gens chez eux
ah s'il passe voilà s'ils peuvent être
sans oxygène retrouvés sont
effectivement aller les choses en prix
c'est que la populace à la recrudescence
est en partie liée au fait qu' il y
avait eu bon nous sommes si on peut dire
en confinement pratiquement continuelle
depuis depuis un nom sachant qu'il ya eu
des périodes de déconfinement mais les
écoles sont fermées depuis déjà 13 mois
les écoles les universités et donc ce
qui était essentiel et avait réouvert
nous faisons de loups nous sommes de
nouveau corps feu depuis deux semaines
et puis le confinement dans selon les
états selon les villes regrets mais
c'est effectivement du fait que beaucoup
de personnes au beaucoup de personnes
une partie de la population ont un peu
laissé de côté les mesures de précaution
le port du masque la distanciation qui
est un peu difficile dont une métropole
qui sont très peuplées comme b on parle
aussi de ce fameux
double variant variant à double mutation
tout est le variant en d1 est ce que il
serait en cause aussi puisque on appris
qu'il serait beaucoup plus contagieux
alors dans l'immédiat le variant le plus
répandu qu'on sait le vario anglais donc
on n a pas encore de les donner pour
pouvoir dire qu'elle est en faisant le
séquençage de séquençage n'ai pas fait
de façon systématique pour savoir dans
quelle mesure le double varions indien
est en train de prendre quelle position
il prendre le dans les vidéos et logis
de l'épidémie en inde
mais en l'occurrence pour l'instant
c'est les actes c'est le riz anglais qui
sans être fécondés alors on a vu voilà
sept cette crise cette pénurie de
médicaments sait également qu'un marché
noir s'est organisée justement pour
faire face à ce manque d'oxygène et de
médicaments c'est un accès alternative
qui peut être dangereux également pour
les citoyens comment est ce que les
autorités gèrent ce problème absolument
donc lâche les autorités fait circuler
et surtout par des groupes pas les
systèmes de sociaux des groupes pro des
arts etc
les coordonnées des distributeurs des
distributeurs officiels
mais c'est vrai que souvent
les numéros de téléphone qui ne
répondent pas donc c'est un petit peu
difficile mais il faut aller surtout à
la source c'est-à-dire les compagnies
pharmaceutiques qui produisent qui
produisent leur aide les médicaments
dont on a besoin
donc merci beaucoup en tout cas
véronique dinan d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
pédiatre à bombay chef du service de
soins palliatifs pour enfants au bail
djerba wadia hospital